what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone we just become best friends yep
oh no oh no oh no see this is why you
guys need to watch the video version of
this podcast sophia just dabbed
do you want to see another one i'm
pulling a bow and arrow out of my
bag pulling it back oh
gosh thank you oh gosh welcome back
welcome back with your favorite sisters
sophia
and sistine if it's your first time here
welcome if it's not welcome back
you hate it but i'm still doing it you
know what's weird i feel like we haven't
done this podcast in a month
like i don't know why i have so much
energy energy while shooting it today
don't laugh at me because it's stupid
right i'm usually the one that's
stuttering sister i call you out oh
god no we haven't done a sister duo in a
little bit yeah we're back baby sister
episode number two
again stronger harder and we've got some
and you shall receive
today is going to be a super fun episode
we're going to do the usual
wax and wayne maybe a little conspiracy
theory action we're going to do some
unsolicited advice and we wanted to add
a little bit of a topic that people they
i guess
unsolicited advice but this is more of a
topic we were always wanting to talk
about
because have you seen that take
backwards like let me add a little spice
to this
spice like the guy from the salt you
know the salt guy that used to salt the
uh
the steaks dm sistine a while back she
didn't answer
what could have been he could have had
really good steaks why did you just
out me like that there's nothing i'm
more delighted to be out of the loop on
and
then the salt guy is still relevant i
don't think so
i have no idea who it is but i want to
know now you know i actually do you
remember that
episode on billions he was in it does he
own a restaurant does he go around
around he does
oh wait that's what i thought i think
you have to pay like 500
for him to come to your table personally
and salt your steak like that
i think we save up all of our money that
we make on ads and then we just higher
entire there's just salt
all over
is he going to be the daddy that the the
psychic says
last episode sistine's going to marry a
daddy yeah that's what a psychic told me
and maybe it's saltbae
it might be coming very full circle okay
let's get into the water wayne do you
want me to start out do you want to go
out you start with the wax
all right so um we did this really fun
thing
the other night we saw it on tick-tock
and i don't think it's a trend anymore
but we were like we've always
wanted to do this but we just dove head
right into it
so i made a powerpoint and so did
sistine
and it was a secret until we came
together and it was supposed to be
something funny
oh you're explaining it terribly no i'm
not yes you are oh what
it's this game that you can play with
your girlfriends group of friends
whatever and it's called powerpoint
night
and so every person that you're hanging
out with makes a powerpoint
and it can be any sort of topic
something like
guys that i regret hooking up with and
then you just have a funny powerpoint
about it or like
two conspiracy theories of like or like
yeah why nick jonas is
yeah or like cartoons that i think are
hot and it's just like really really
funny and yeah
involves drinking too right it can
involve drinking we didn't do that but
it was just between sistine scarlet and
i but cece and i took
full force into this and we really put a
lot of time into our uh
i want to say i highly recommend yeah
really
playing this powerpoint game it is so
much fun
what topic did you do again i did people
i would
love to punch in the face if i had the
opportunity
if they were held down and i had one
punch it was so funny
and it was not just celebrities they
were celebrities but it was also people
i know like friends and family
it was hilarious she had elevator music
going on i did i explained like why i
would punch them
how i would punch them um photos of
why i would punch them i'm really not an
aggressive person but you know there are
people
some people have a hittable face
hittable face or like they've done
something that you just want to punch
them for sure
so i i gave all my reasoning explanation
to them and they they enjoyed it but i
think sistine's
i'm gonna can i just
is a very um very uh twisted person
with this stuff hold on you are she
loves the thing she loves like
the dark kind of troubled people in
shows all right sophia let me explain it
you do yeah please hold on
hold your horses lady
i really sounded like a lunatic out here
well i sounded like like
i'm gonna try to say a pc version of my
title all right uh
my powerpoint was essentially
sociopaths in television and film
that i think are attractive that was my
pc
that she would let them make out with
her that i would kiss
so it was everyone from willis cracking
stuff
i feel so innocent it's like it's what's
so good that i would kiss
i'm trying i would kiss i'm trying to
make it very pc so it was people from
american horror story to peaky blinders
just
but don't say some of the characters
because i was okay so
thomas shelby thomas shelby [ __ ]
blind
i thought it was like evan peters who
played tate in american horror story
you did um jason
game of thrones what was his name but
here's the thing i
am not saying i like these people in
life i i like their character
so i always get disappointed because
i'll see um killigan murphy i'm probably
saying his name wrong just out and about
with his family on the street and i'm
like
that's not thomas shelby it's different
haircut different clothes i like thomas
shelby yeah she's saying the character
but it was really twisted but funny as
hell because there was people i didn't
even like
remember that were like oh you even said
the guy that played it
oh yeah the clown i said he was
pennywise
as the clowner as the man
my biggest fear is clowns and so when
she put this up i
literally lost so i can't as you can see
we're like crying just
thinking back on it you guys have to
play this game it is so much fun but
i want you to talk about your wayne
because i didn't even know this until
right now seeing it um i was on
speakerphone with my little sister the
other day i was in her room and i
answered the phone because i you know
sometimes you get random numbers
and you're like oh let me just see what
it is maybe it's an appointment i was
just saying i get a ton of calls from
like redondo beach and now you never
know i don't know why
you never know i don't know anything
right it could you could have won a
lottery you never know answer the phone
i answer it and it was a collect call
from prison and it was like hello
you're getting a collect call from
houston prison and i always said i'm not
hanging up i want to see what this is
about
your inmate caller diego would like to
speak to you
how would you like to pursue the payment
i go let's go and i look at each other
like oh my god this is crazy right i
hang up he calls me three more times i
was like diego
and she's like i'm flattered and then i
get two voicemails
and will you were just saying our
producer will just said that he got a
collect call from prison recently
i've gotten two voicemails from a
president what's going on are they guys
or girls
uh men oh interesting my theory is that
it's a couple of guys who it's kind of
sad they got nobody else left to call so
they're just pushing buttons
really you know yeah i could see that
and then they're like
maybe someone will talk to me oh see i
was i'm not kidding i was actually so
tempted to proceed yeah i called back i
googled the number i was like i gotta
talk to this guy
i kind of want to okay let's make a
let's make a deal the next time we get a
call we have to
i really don't know if it's a good idea
i'm sure someone will get our credit
card information yeah we'll get [ __ ]
but
yeah i don't know if i'm like the the
sane one in the situation but i think no
she's not the same one she's just
jealous that no one from prison wants to
talk to you ha ha
i find that really hilarious that that
keeps happening to you because cecine
has an unfortunate uh
tale with her phones like every single
time she has her phone
it's getting hacked it's getting blocked
it's getting like any
under the sun but people that were
stalking me wouldn't get a hold of her
number i don't know how
and like call her at least 80 times 100
actually more than that probably like
500 times honestly i wish i was kidding
my icloud's gotten hacked twice
my number's gotten released you're doing
wrong i think i go on a lot of
um bootleg websites and i just put all
of no just random
you know those bad ad bloggers they're
like don't do it and i'm like maybe i
should
and like yeah right i put my email put
my phone in they have all my info
i give it away yeah it's my fault it's
like free candy okay
uh sophie and i were talking about
uh friendships in l.a and we find that
it's
it's hard not even in a light in general
it's hard
to maintain a friendship with a girl it
is really hard but i think it's also
the longevity of a friendship it's
really hard to
i think when you're in a relationship
basically with your friend and not in a
sexual way just
in a relationship with your friend and
things start to go south
you don't really know how to approach it
yes and i think a lot of times like
you're
in this friendship and it's going well
but you can see some red flags and you
can see that you aren't really happy in
the friendship and it sounds like
you're dating this person i know it does
sound like you kind of are you commit a
lot of your time and it's actually
interesting because
whenever we ask you guys to dm us
questions most of the questions have
to do with how do i break up with my
friends yeah
and i'm really happy we're doing this
because i think sistine and i we do like
to be goofy and everything on the show
but we also do
want to talk about these topics i think
are really important and today's topic i
think we just want to just ramble about
and see if maybe you guys get some
tidbits of information you pick up on
that and maybe we'll learn something
from each other
we're gonna we're gonna talk about when
to leave the friendship how to break up
when to rebuild the friendship to sell
yeah and how to find a new friend
so stick with us i'm just kidding let's
see how this goes
um okay so from my experience when to
leave i feel like
i have a lot of friends from high school
and then when they all went to college
everyone sort of spread out around the
country so now
i'm literally the last one left in l.a
so i
have to try to put myself out there and
sometimes
it's hard because you want something to
work and you're sort of forcing a
friendship and
deep down you know it's not you guys
just aren't compatible
so i found myself for example in a
friendship with a girl that was
almost draining like it was more effort
for me
than it was for her like i saw
everything that i was giving to her in
this
relationship i was like the one always
making the plans always reaching out
always
always yeah always showering with
compliments always you know
paying the bill and that stuff does i
like doing that
yeah but it's hard when you get zero
percent back right so it's you know what
i mean it has to be a marriage it needs
to be ying and yang because you want to
feel like
you're getting something out of this too
and if you're putting all your energy
into
one basket or all your eggs into one
basket and you're getting
no goodies back it really just becomes
one-sided and you become depressed about
it you have to take a step back and look
at
okay so they're gaining a lot from this
friendship but what are you gaining
and so when i asked myself that i go oh
my god i'm gaining nothing
right i'm literally gaining nothing from
this relationship and you
were telling me that you had this
experience with a girlfriend that kind
of always like teased you and put you
down so
my sense of hers was more she put a lot
of energy into a relationship
my problem when i found out it was kind
of more time to leave
was when i saw the jokes of me being
called oh you're so stupid you're so
silly you're so dumb you're so
like you're such a [ __ ] like all this
stuff and it was a joke but then it
started to become like
every single time i said something and
i'm a goof like i like to just crack
jokes and it may be stupid or not but
it became insulting it was more like
they're laughing at you it was more
laughing at me not with me and i'm like
okay i can i can take a few
jobs i don't really care but when it
comes to the point where i feel like you
know there
could be a little true truth in this
choice what is
what's that saying it's like to every
joke there's a little yeah there's a
little truth in it i'm like okay maybe
this girl really doesn't like me
or maybe there's like some part of her
that isn't wanting to be my friend as
much as like i thought she wanted to be
or maybe she's going through something
but
i've started to feel really upset every
time i'd hang out with her so i was like
i don't really know if i want to
continue this friendship if it's going
to continue like this unless i say
something
yeah and i'm really bad at confrontation
so this is where sophie and i differ
because
sophia kept that friendship today yeah i
broke up with that friend and we are
currently not together anymore
so how did you do that though so there's
there's i feel like there's two ways to
go about it and it sort of depends
on the level of friendship that you guys
had the duration that you guys have
known each other that all
sort of plays a factor for me since it
was fairly new
i and i was a little bit scared of this
person i'm not gonna lie
i started to slowly pull away
and just stopped answering gradually and
eventually that person got the message
and it was interesting because the
it's almost like you're in a
relationship with them yeah like the
more you ignore them the more that they
want to see you again
your friend is basically your boyfriend
or your girlfriend whatever it is
because
you're going to dinner you're texting
every day you guys are getting emotional
with each other it really
is a relationship and i feel like
breaking up with a friend sometimes is a
little bit harder oh 100
i know that sounds kind of crazy but if
you've known this friend since you were
like born it really can be definitely so
i feel like that's number one that's
what i did with this girlfriend
but option two which is the probably the
wiser option would be
to be up front with them yeah tell them
how you're feeling if they
can't see it from your point of view and
they don't understand or they're not
willing to make a change
then that sort of should be your answer
because that just shows a level of how
much they care for you or not yeah
that's true
so you so i have a totally different
thing yeah so i
actually wanted to when she brought up
this topic about losing a friend i
wanted to talk about how
you can lose a friend but also when to
reintroduce that friend because i do
know that sometimes
we all go through our ups and downs and
whether it's like someone we're dating
which is in this case i had a friend
that i've known since high school that i
was really really close with
and she started dating this person and
it really just became a relationship
with the three of us and
unfortunately this guy was super toxic
and he would get involved and it became
our fight and she never wanted to hang
out and so it was really really hard for
me
to continue this friendship that seems
to be the catalyst of a lot of
issues when it comes to girlfriends
because i know that i have been
in that girl's position where i was in a
relationship with a guy that was toxic
for me and i was putting it out on my
girlfriend and she goes what the hell
are you doing so this is the problem is
that and this is what happened with you
you tell the person or she told you this
guy is really not a great guy like you
need to you deserve better like this is
what you should do and that you don't
want to hear
you don't want to hear that if you're in
love it's like love is blind and
i think that you can't understand what a
person's feeling unless they're in their
situation that's what i always try to go
into every
understanding of my friend's
relationship so unfortunately after high
school
she was still dating him and it totally
fizzled out we got into like a blow up
fight about basically this person and it
really was just like
it just snowballed and we both went to
separate colleges
and then i think having time apart once
she dumped him
or he i don't remember and she started
to grow and figure out
her self-worth and then i even just
found out who i was
it was almost natural that we came
together but i think a really good way
to reintroduce a friend into your life
again
is making those little text messages
here and they're going hey i'm in town i
would love to get coffee or lunch
check up on them occasionally like
slowly build up that process like you're
getting a new friend she was the type of
friend to you that
from the beginning it was like a match
made at home oh yeah this was like mike
and she's my
sister almost so she was worth worth
totally worth rebuilding like i wanted
to rebuild it in general but i think
that
you have i had to like step on extras
and so did she it was really
nerve-wracking because we both did have
this kind of huge falling out
and once you kind of gain that trust
back and if you've already had that love
in the beginning it really will come up
super quick like when you with an axe
when you talk to an axe after you
talk to him again all of those like old
feelings and like that comfort
is all there and that's the same with
the friendship but just like a
relationship
you need to slowly integrate yourselves
into each other's lives before just like
jumping cut first
for sure um and on the opposite end of
that
moving on from that friendship yeah it's
just like moving on from
a boyfriend you want to get over someone
you get under someone new
and that is a new friend and guess what
we don't like doing it's really hard to
make new friends i'm gonna tell you
actually i like it i like it but you're
you're sophia is a good texter
i have such anxiety about going out and
trying to make a new friend yeah it's
really
scary and i feel like a lot of people
can relate to that and i envy this one
girl who we're going to bring on the
podcast she's a new friend of mine her
name is olivia
and she we met at an event pre-covered
and then post
or sort of during covet she dm'd me was
like hey
we should be friends let's get lunch and
that i don't think
people realize that how much those
messages mean to them like that meant
so much to me because i would have never
had the guts to go out and do that
absolutely and you don't realize
how much just sending that text message
to someone or from someone
is so it made my rake and it was it
started it off on such a good note and
we're still friends we hang out every
single week
right and so moral of the story is go
out there
put yourself out there yep make a new
friend because everyone knows
everyone needs fun you just need one you
do you don't need two
i got one she got one let me tell you
the hard facts of life
what is it i'm a lonely little cow how
lonely
very lonely i'm being serious right now
actually no i
it's i there was a long period
especially during covered where i just
felt really alone like i have my
girlfriends
i have this one best friend but she's
away at college yeah so it is
hard being alone and you feel like
because sophia was going out to dinners
and she was seeing her friends well this
is the difference and i have to give
sistine a little bit of credit
and i think some people can relate to
this too sistine lived in new york
for a bit and then she moved back to l.a
so a lot of her friends that she made
were back still in new york
and i feel like when you're moving into
a new place and you have to rebuild all
these new friendships it is really hard
i was already in college in la
so i had four years to build these
friendships you know but it's a little
bit easier
that's true that's true the only bright
side is
i've got a sister and technically she's
a friend that's never allowed to leave
she
third wheels with all my friendships and
i love it and they love her
so it works i'm kind of the fun party
girl she's a fun party guy any party
all my friends now they go hey um i have
this party happening tonight
have your sister come like of course
like they don't want me they want tina
they want tina they don't want sister
party girl team of course of course of
course
i think we should transition into what
i'm super excited about because i think
i
left a really um high expectation for
you in terms of
conspiracy theory i think i talked about
lizard people
which may or may not be what we are
because we did think dad might be a
lizard
but you have something for us today
ladies and gentlemen
i have brought in a conspiracy that no
one in this studio saw
coming bomb all right
let me try to think of a title for it
you didn't even this
is the chuck e cheese conspiracy theory
pause for dramatic effect
okay wait oh well
so so this is the theory what can i say
when was the last time you were at chuck
e cheese
chuck e cheese is like maybe the biggest
throwback i've ever heard
maybe when i was 13 yeah really well
have you been to chuck e cheese
uh i have it's been a long time it's but
you've been right yeah
wrong wrong what are you talking about
wrong i don't know wait here let me try
this
he's trying something
no it's too long i wanted something
really good sounds like a plane landing
oh my god the chuck e cheese
i love this okay okay this is the theory
so and i'm sure everyone here has had
their infamous pizza correct it tastes
good i'm not gonna lie
it's thebomb.com you got a little show
that happens all the little characters
you gonna let me do my theory i'm just
saying i'm trying to set the scene i'm
trying to set the scene
let me have this you got lizard people
all right god
virgo take the mic put the mic down
thank you
sit back and enjoy lady all right here's
the theory
if a customer orders pizza from chuck e
cheese
and they don't finish the pizza for
example they have a few pieces left over
the employee takes that pizza back into
the kitchen
puzzles it rearranges it into a new
pizza with other
leftover pieces reheats it and re-serves
it to a new customer
no i knew you were going to say that no
so i have that that's so gross they
wouldn't like re so old pizza
in the kitchen that people didn't eat
and then pizza that would just come in
that still wasn't finished they just
re-push it together
so this isn't something i just pulled
out of my behind
all right there have been yahoo and
reddit threads from
10 years ago talking about this everyone
from the washington post to buzzfeed
everyone's made
videos about it like youtubers famous
youtubers made videos about it
so chuck you also please don't come for
me please don't sue us this is unless
you give us um like a free
free token oh yeah i sent a ticket so we
can buy stuff
um so this conspiracy obviously hit
me in a very sore spot because this
pizza was our childhood and now
there are managers that come out and
they say oh my god
absolutely not chuck e cheese did not do
that
the pizza is handmade this is what they
say it's handmade
so sometimes the pieces shrink that's
why they're not always
even and then some employees are
completely confirming
and saying yep they do this 100 no
so uh wait that's nasty i know you're
still probably obsessed about it right
a little bit yeah i mean i it's just
like hard to sophia you're not sold yet
are you not really
i mean just sounds gross but it could be
i don't know
well do you have a i have a game oh
wait a game we're playing a game do i
get a prize
oh yes you do get a prize if you win i
do they're surprised
so this is the game okay we're playing a
game called chuck e cheese or regular
pizza
i'm gonna show you a series of pictures
and you're gonna tell me
if it's a chuck e cheese pizza remember
chuck e cheese pizza the pieces
do not align to a full circle this would
be very easy though or it's a regular
pizza i threw a couple they're curved
all right here we go if you get them all
right you win a prize
okay
a normal pizza
that is incorrect this is the chuck e
cheese pizza look at the edges it looks
oh i didn't see the bottom though he's
already lost pizza number two
yeah yeah oh that looks like um
cpk's pizza that's not the question is
it a regular picture
regular regular correct is it cpk no i
don't know
pizza number three
i think that's regular no it's not it's
not regular i can't see the bottom one
how are you so bad at this game i saw
these are trick questions
does this look like a full pizza circle
to you no there's like one totally fine
i mean
i just i feel like bad pizza that is a
bad piece of chuck e cheese oh my gosh
all right here we go pizza number four
that looks like domino's that must be
real yeah you got the domino's ranch
last pizza pizza number five for all the
marbles
that's a that's oh you're making me
really stressed if i get this wrong
looks like ingredients chuck e cheese
wouldn't have yeah that's what i'm
thinking too
it's not chuck e cheese so that looks
like there's truffle on top and that's
too fancy for chuck e cheese
that's incorrect it's chunky cheese what
they have truffle on their pizza
this doesn't truffle they're meatballs
they're like meat that looks horrible
but look sophia if you're looking
closely right yeah it doesn't
look at the edges yeah they're totally
unaligned well i
really butchered that one wait what was
the prize though
i guarantee you had no prize it was like
a hug i ordered a chucky cheese pizza
they're like on their ear now and the
mouse is that was a good game
you know okay so guys if you ever see
pizza that looks like it's
so i don't know if this is true or
whatever i i had a feeling
that you were gonna ruin this somehow so
i brought in a few extra quick
conspiracies just to fix what we just
did i didn't ruin it
it's okay here are some other quick
conspiracies if that one wasn't so we're
having a
conspiracy lightning round okay so this
is a good one
yep ready the pants industry
and the purse industry are working
together to keep
women's pockets small in order to force
us to buy
purses what
industry in the purse industry they work
together in order to keep women's
pockets smaller
that's not true because if i had giant
pockets that went down to my knees i
wouldn't wear it
i'm sorry would you buy pants that had
pockets to your knees no but that's why
i'm saying that's why they wouldn't make
it for
that just a theory here's another one
i gotta rationalize this oh my god go
ahead all right so the reason
disney came out with the movie called
frozen
was that when you googled disney frozen
you would get information about the
movie frozen
yeah and not websites talking about walt
disney's frozen body
that's so trippy is he frozen
absolutely no he's not is walt disney
frozen
yes no is that is do you know dude
are you sure i'm like what
sophia you go where sophia it's a
conspiracy
under space mountain horn imagine if
he's frozen under the
matterhorn he is in the body of the
matterhorn that's crazy wait now i want
to talk about though
walt disney frozen so why would he be
frozen when
when did he even pass away you're asking
questions i do not know the answers
you're this conspiracy theorist why
aren't you like how's that okay i'll
guess i'll look it up
if he resurrects and creates the
ultimate worldwide disney
attraction here we go an article from
chicago on twenty mars
is walt disney's body frozen rumor has
it that the animation
legend yeah there's an ad was frozen
after death
so he could be re-animated in the future
is it a myth read for the truth about i
don't want to
know you'd have to read but when do you
think he would resurrect
if he was frozen well it would certainly
make 2020 even crazier than it is
well you hear it first he might be
resurrected
2020. all right thanks for that really
trash segment
of chuck e cheese or regular pizza
i liked it i liked it okay and we're
back with another unsolicited advice
segment we got to get better at doing
these
yeah but i want a disclaimer from now on
sophia and i will only be reading
questions if you follow these
instructions
if you go to the apple podcast app and
you search unwaxed podcast
you go to the section that says write a
review you write a review
give us five stars and you put your
question in your review and that's the
only way
we will read your questions and answer
them okay so this one
this one listener did the extr did the
extra most extraordinary
what did she do that was so extra
extraordinary well she just followed my
rules and like i really appreciate it
thank you so her question is i'd love to
hear what you both think about age gap
relationships in this day and age
what are some things to consider about
being a 20-something now versus
what it may have been like 30 something
years ago
would love to hear your opinions okay so
i feel like
i'm so indifferent about it because i
today when i see
a person in their early 20s dating
someone in their 40s
i personally don't care like they can do
what they want it's their life
i think maybe that's because we're
around a relationship
constantly that has that big age gap
because our parents
what is their age gap uh well our mom is
oh i shouldn't say the h but i think
they're like why that's not a bad thing
yeah
isn't it like inappropriate to say like
the woman's age whatever i think that's
it
yes so i see like 20 they're like a 23
years difference
yeah yeah but it's so funny because we
look at that relationship
and it's incredible yeah like better
than most marriages i've ever seen
right like they're constantly laughing
and i think what helps is when you have
um like our dad is such a young soul
yeah that is the difference
but i this is what i think is the con on
the other side of it because
i think having an age gap it does have a
lot of pros i think you can learn from
the other person they have a totally
different perspective
they're raised in a different generation
but at the same time
with even like even our parents can
attest to this
that you guys have really different
mindsets in the way you were raised and
the way you go about things and so
it really is a matter of fact if you
want that super mature relationship
very early on well maybe the guy that
you're dating or whoever you're dating
want to date is
that energetic lively spirit i know my
dad is
so it he feels i think he's more 50 than
he is his actual age
i think for us that's the problem i mean
at least for me i'll speak for me and
then you can answer yeah
i think the oldest i'd go up would
probably be
right now because i'm only 22 like five
to seven years and that's that's about
it i think
because i'm still young i kind of want
to date people young
and you've gone out though for example
someone that was
i think like 30 yeah and it was almost
it was uh almost
no shame for the 30 year olds out there
but it was it's just there is a big
there's a difference
i think for me i would go 10 i'm 24. so
10 years older
11 years older so that's like 35. that's
a man
i i don't think i would mind i think my
personality though it really depends on
your personality and i
i think that i sometimes can sway to be
a little bit more on the serious side
with some things and i think i could
probably handle it
but i i find no shame in it but i think
that really make sure
if you are going to go into an age gap
that's a large relationship that you are
ready for it because it is for the right
it is different
for the right reasons for love but we're
all about
if y'all are in love freaking go for it
but also
i don't know if you should be like 50
and 18.
i think that's a little odd i know so
those are the drastic ones
i'm like we were watching this show what
was it marrying to millions and there
was that one
guy he was maybe 65 and the girl was
21. yeah i think she just turned 21 i
would say that's a little
bigger i don't know if i can handle it
she seems like she can handle it i
couldn't but i think that's a little too
much but when we say age graph
we're saying at most like for us it's i
know this sounds crazy but like 20
but other people probably think that's a
really really big age gap so yeah
we're just jaded we mean we see our we
see our parents happy and having fun
so if if that happens in the future i
guess it doesn't
happen so be mature enough for it make
sure the relationship
is the right one and for the right
reasons and that you're comfortable and
make sure you're not just pushing into
it because it sounds great make sure
you're actually
wanting it well said thank you what's
the next question
um well another question that we've gone
a lot
was about our diet and our fitness and
what we eat in a day
and i can just kind of like say what i
do because it's super easy um
honestly it really does change every
month i think even sistine can say this
we'll go really really hard for a month
and then we'll go totally off
for a month right now i'm just walking
like four miles a day and then
doing some like ab and butt workouts
that's kind of it i have a smoothie
every morning
i'll tell you whatever i eat like a
healthy dinner i i mean it wasn't that
bad it was like i just like walk
well it's true i don't really i wouldn't
say i do like an intense workout every
day i think
actually my body has looked better when
i haven't been hitting it
really really hard but some people are
different so
i think that um we're really conscious
about what we put in our body though
yeah because you know
it's eighty percent fun healthy food
twenty percent fun food
eighty percent fun food that would be a
dream hot no and we also do
intermittent fasting yeah we do so we
probably eat breakfast around 10 30 and
we have our dinner at 5
30. yeah which takes some getting used
to but honestly that has been
cestine does that i eat breakfast at
like nine i can't do until 10 i get
really really hungry
i think if you somehow work in an active
activity at least four times a week yeah
you're
solid that's what i'm doing right now
yeah my biggest suggestion is honestly
to try
everything i do think intermittent
fasting if you can eat
not so late at night and not snack and
it really does change how your body
feels in the morning yeah drink a ton of
water we drink like an absurd amount of
water every single day yeah
and we force ourselves it's not like we
love the taste but we know that it makes
us feel better
also what i like to do because i think
working out is boring sometimes i like
to go on youtube and there are so
many fun videos that sort of trick you
into working out like the other day i
did
a tick tock it was a 45 minute tick tock
dance
hit workout and i was dripping sweat it
was
horrible yeah but it was so much fun
they're like you just burned 700
calories and like what the heck i was
just
hitting the renegade like what you're
like i was just dabbing
maybe go on youtube just fine there's so
many good people if you guys need some
suggestions you can obviously dm me and
i'll tell you
um but yeah i just think that find your
find your rhythm find what works for you
because at the end of the day sofia
again we're always switching it up yeah
it's never been consistent but we feel
our healthiest
when we've been working out less which
is interesting and if your mind isn't
right your body isn't right i think
everything is very cohesive so make sure
everything is aligned
before doing anything because you want
to make sure that you're going into
working out and eating healthy and
changing up your diet for the right
reasons as well yes
wow okay i actually liked today because
i know that we always go like
kind of crazy i mean the conspiracy
theory was a little bit off the wagon
for a second but we got back on it
and i like that we give people advice we
talk more because i think that
people want to know sometimes what we
say yeah a bit more and
um we would love to keep hearing from
you guys so remember what sistine said
go to the apple podcast page give us
that five stars nothing less if i see a
three
you ain't getting your question answered
they're just not nice
it's not nice to give us three stars
either so that's what i'm saying
oh yeah yeah you say i wasn't nice
whatever but then write the question in
the reviews and we will
absolutely answer it we'll answer every
single one maybe we'll just have a rapid
fire
unsolicited advice if you guys like all
just pile in at once
yeah yeah we have nothing else to do so
let's just do it
okay well well thank you guys so much
for having um
for having us today
ah
thanks for uh tuning in to the [ __ ] show
we
love you guys we will see you next
tuesday bye
from all of us here at the show thanks
for staying unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts
at sophia stallone and at sistine
stallone and be sure to follow the show
at unwax
podcast your producer is will sterling
we'll see you next week